hey what's up
mkbhd here so let's talk max for a
minute
so next to me here is the brand new
27-inch imac you may have seen that
announcement and this guy is essentially
a spec bump a refresh
of a lot of really important pieces
inside of
the same design imac we've always known
and first of all i've already said like
in previous videos that i love that
apple is doing more
consistent updates to products at least
lately because in my ideal world
the tech just keeps getting updated over
and over regardless of whatever cycle
we're on
whenever you buy a new piece of tech
it's just the latest version available
kind of like what tesla does but
computers don't all work that way so
this is about as good as we'll get thank
you for keeping the imac
updated apple that being said
because of the inevitable imac refresh
the updated design we're expecting and
the apple silicon transition for max
looming on the horizon it's not such a
straightforward answer to just
recommend getting this or not but let me
just show you what's new with this imac
because it's actually a really nice
update all things considered
so it's mostly the 27-inch imac getting
the good stuff
and first of all it's updated to the
latest 10th gen intel chips
and radeon graphics so this one i have
here is actually spec pretty nicely
with the highest end 10 core i9 and you
can get it with up to 128 gigs of ram
that is thankfully still user
replaceable by this little door here on
the back of the 27 inch
and you have the new radeon 5000 series
gpus
minus spec as you can see and i've only
had it for a limited time about two days
but i have obviously had no performance
issues
on this brand new machine and benchmarks
show that it is
a solid performance upgrade there is a
reason for this new chip but i think the
biggest change is actually
that the hard drives are now gone from
this lineup
those fusion drives are also now gone it
is all
ssds all the way through the line up to
eight terabytes which is sick now
honestly this is kind of long overdue
hard drives instead of ssds in
premium machines in 2020 should
basically be a niche thing at this point
the prices come down so much for fast
ssds
which these are that it's a no-brainer
so i'm glad to see ssds
the one weird thing is if you go spec
out a 21.5 inch imac right now you can
still
find a one terabyte fusion drive i think
that is the last hard drive shipping
in an apple product right now at least
default
kill that apple but you know what makes
me really happy to be able to say
they've improved the quality
of the webcams this is now the look of
the new 1080p webcam
in the imac 27-inch
looks much better again it's not like
some amazing thing but it's not just the
resolution
1080p it's a physically better sensor
and
of course you can see the image quality
here there's also
the microphone quality which you're
hearing which now is these new studio
quality mics which
again is a bit of an exaggeration but
there is one additional microphone
around the back of the mac
for better echo and noise cancellation i
guess it makes sense that they could
upgrade the physical size of the webcam
inside the imac because there's more
room
inside this bigger machine um
i'm still going to keep asking for a
better webcam in their laptops but
again when you put it in this this all
in one it makes it that much better
of a media machine in these times where
we're doing a lot more
video conferencing and virtual work
they've also improved
the speakers at the bottom of the imac
here so there's now a dedicated audio
controller on the t2 chip
and personally while i can't really hear
much of a max volume difference i mean
it's already been pretty loud
i can attest for an improvement in the
fidelity and just overall quality
at most of the existing volume levels
which is always great because a lot of
people
who use imacs use these built-in
speakers but the feature i was most
interested in
when we saw this announcement the other
day is the new nano texture
matte glass which conveniently enough
this mac behind me
actually has it's hard to tell because
there's almost no reflections but
i think this is an option first of all
that i love and that i think a lot of
people buying imacs
will also love so a lot of you probably
remember the nano texture option first
appearing in the 5
000 pro display xdr from last year
it was a thousand dollar option but
generally it dramatically reduced glare
and now these things are an order of
magnitude easier to work with in this
well-lit studio environment so having
this same finish
without having to change the color or
anything about the bezels
is great it massively cuts down on
reflections as you can tell
and now you can use the imac in rooms
with
windows behind you or lamps across the
room or just any other types of
uncontrollable light that you just don't
have to worry about anymore this is
implemented super well my only question
is
it's a 500 option here on the imac it
was a it still has a thousand dollar
option on the pro display xdr
why is this not available on the imac
pro if you know
pros will use it because it's on the pro
display and you know regular people love
it because matte displays are everywhere
and you put it on the imac
why not put it on the machine both pros
and some regular people
yet get so i wouldn't be surprised if we
saw this
eventually get added to imac pro so
anyway all that great stuff being said
you should still think very carefully
about whether you should buy whatever
you should spend
starting at 17.99 whether you should
spend that much money on a new machine
right now at this point in 2020 because
there are some things looming on the
horizon
which are the inevitable imac redesign
and the apple silicon transition see the
imac
is long overdue for redesign and i'm not
just saying that because people like to
just change for the sake of change
they've been using essentially this same
design
for about eight years now since 2012 and
it's just
dated now like look at the size of these
bezels
where else in anywhere in apple's lineup
do you see bezels this big
the chin being this big even the port
layout around the back
this this is generally a machine that
could use a refresh and so the rumor is
apple's been working on this
a sort of imac redesign that looks
something like the pro display xdr
or the ipad pro with generally more
squared off edges
thinner bezels and all that same great
performance
that would feel a lot more worth the
money
whenever that happens but even if let's
say you are fine with this design
there is also now the already announced
transition of all macs to apple silicon
that they announced at wwdc and that's
when we saw apple get on stage and talk
about the planned
two-year transition period to start
moving all of their macs from intel's
x86 architecture to apple silicon
and there are some seriously impressive
performance and efficiency
and thermal promises that come from all
the potential of moving to apple silicon
and we're all hoping this transition
goes as smoothly as possible
but importantly if you are a shopper
considering getting an imac
there are a lot of unanswered questions
just in general
about what will happen to intel max
once this transition period is over and
how long will it take before intel max
slowly start to get treated like second
class
max and start to get less updates and
just generally start to fade into the
past
so in the case of this new imac update
and every single intel mac update
between now and that transition
consider two things one how immediately
do you actually need to get a new
computer
and two how long do you plan on keeping
that mac like sometimes it can be kind
of hard to know but if you know
generally you're a pretty quick updater
in like three or four years you know
you'll probably upgrade again
or if you need a computer now or let's
say you just
like this design then get it because
this is a pretty great mac
in general a lot of things that are
great about it like i talked about in
the first half of this video but because
this is such a
solid easy to recommend all-in-one
there's a lot of buyers of imax
that have their computer for that they
want it to be good for seven
eight nine ten years which is an
incredibly long time to use a computer
but people keep their computers for a
very long time when they buy imax and
not a lot of people watching this
channel
fall into that demographic but those
people
should probably wait another year
or two for the inevitable transition
to apple silicon or that imac redesign
or maybe they both happen at the same
time but
that will make it feel much more worth
the money
then again a lot of those people
probably don't care about apple silicon
or designs of imax so maybe i'm just
preaching to no one here there's
something called
the osborne effect which i'm sure a lot
of apple users have considered which is
a social phenomenon of customers
canceling or deferring orders for a
current
soon to be obsolete product as an
unexpected drawback
of a company's announcing a future
product prematurely
you can imagine applying that to this
current situation which is people
deciding not to buy this pretty great
imac that would probably be fine for
them
because of the intel 2 apple silicon
transition expected in about a year
maybe that'll be a better one and i
think apple's thought a lot about this
and
at the end of the day this imac was
still going to come out anyway because
apple's relationship with intel is
is a long time coming and these products
have just been
road mapped for years now so it was
going to happen anyway but
i think if you're a potential customer
just take that extra beat to think about
whether you need a computer
now or if you can wait a year or two for
what will probably be a bit more future
proof
anyway that's my two cents
that's been the video thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace
you